Attorney General William Bar is under
scrutiny today after the Justice
Department abruptly dropped its criminal
case against Michael Flynn he was
president Trump's first national
security adviser the retired general
admitted lying to the FBI during the
Russian investigation then renounced his
guilty plea before he was sentenced Barr
explained his decision in an exclusive
interview with senior investigative
correspondent that's Catherine Herridge
what should Americans take away from
your actions in the Flynn case today I
was concerned that people were feeling
there were two standards of justice in
his country and that the political and
that the justice or the law enforcement
process was being used to play political
games based on new evidence the Justice
Department said the former national
security advisors 2017 FBI interview was
unjustified and done without any
legitimate investigative basis just a
month into his administration President
Trump said he fired National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn for lying to vice
president pence about his conversations
with and Russian ambassador Sergei kis
lyac following the 2016 election later
in December 2017 Flynn pleaded guilty to
lying to the FBI about his conversations
with the Ambassador during the
presidential transition Flynn has since
tried to withdraw his guilty plea does
the fact remain that he lied well you
know people sometimes plead to things
that turn out not to be crimes newly
unsealed documents show in early 2017
the FBI was going to close its
investigation of Flynn setting a lack of
derogatory information then a senior FBI
agent suddenly intervened they kept it
open for the express purpose of trying
to catch lay a perjury trap for general
Flynn the reversal comes after multiple
public statements from President Trump
who has said Flynn was treated unfairly
he was targeted by the Obama
administration former FBI director James
Comey fired by President Trump for his
handling of the Russia case tweeted
Thursday the Justice Department has lost
its way a charge echoed by Democrats the
president has his attorney general
the hand of the president doing his
political work his personal bidding bar
told CBS News he didn't discuss the
decision with President Trump are you
doing the president's bidding in general
Flynn's case no I'm doing the laws
bidding I'm doing my duty under the law
as I see when history looks back on this
decision how do you think it will be
written well history is written by the
winners so it's largely depends on who's
writing the history but I think a fair
history would say it was it was a good
decision because it it upheld the rule
of law it helped it upheld the standards
of the Department of Justice and it
undid what was it injustice after the
decision President Trump called Flynn an
innocent man but his fate rests with a
federal judge here in Washington DC who
could dismiss the case or according to
one CBS News legal expert call a hearing
with all of the parties given the
extraordinary circumstances the Attorney
General emphasized to CBS News that they
continue to investigate other aspects of
the FBI Russia probe Tony a very
interesting turn of events Catherine
thank you very much